[Musique]
David, je vous signe au ministre de l'
Intérieur très bon moment pour passer au
plaisir de vous rencontrer madame j'ai fait pour la
réunion elle a un programme de
peur accrue et de pouvoir de maladie qui ne
nécessite pas de s'excuser pour le passé n'est-ce pas
Je veux dire ce que tu as dit, je n'ai pas besoin de toi pour
me protéger,
rassure-toi, amour, je ferai ce qu'il faut,
reste en bas,
ça va, ça va,
ces complots ne surgissent pas toujours de l'
extérieur d'un Fister à l'intérieur.
politiciens lâches et menteurs
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait vous devez savoir
comment pensez-vous qu'elle se sentirait si elle portait
un toast
vous ne pouvez pas continuer à protéger les vôtres
ne pouvez pas chauffer c'est un politicien très dangereux
quelqu'un doit faire des trucs
[Musique]
il y a eu  un homme de l'intérieur ne
ressemble plus au ministre de l'Intérieur ne pourrait pas être entre de
meilleures mains
[Musique]